many American Airlines workers say their
new uniforms make them sick and they
want the company to do more to help more
than 3,000 flight attendants and about
200 pilots have filed reports
complaining that their uniforms have
caused rashes hives and breathing
problems Kris Van Cleave is at Reagan
National Airport outside Washington DC
with this medical mystery Kris good
morning good morning so in September
more than 70,000 American Airlines
employees from the Gaeta to the ticket
counter to the folks flying the
airplanes got new uniforms and not long
after that complaints started coming in
and while the airline has offered
several alternatives they have stopped
short of the one that many are calling
for a full recall we're taking a
different approach with our uniform
program american airlines new uniforms
debuted last fall with the company
touting how it included employees in the
process they helped design it they
helped create it they provide vital
feedback to make sure that it functions
out in the operation less than a year
later what is this so this is what I'm
wearing now
flight attendant Joshua Skaar [ __ ]
pieces together his outfit Banana
Republic pair of gray pants I've got a
Calvin Klein white shirt to match the
look of the company issued uniform he
blames for causing itching and worse I
just couldn't even like come to grips of
the fact that a uniform could be causing
this and then your eyes will shut and
then I ended up in the ER yeah
talking to my regular doctor he pretty
much said blow this isn't an allergic
reaction this is chemicals this is a
chemical reaction that's burning your
skin that's irritating your body some of
the thousands who have filed complaints
have shared similar stories and photos
over social media but separate testing
by American the flight attendants Union
and the manufacturer have all shown
chemical levels are within acceptable
limits the airline reports it spent more
than a million dollars to investigate
what's going on but with no clear answer
flight attendants are demanding a recall
Bob Ross is the union president if we
can't find out what the problem is and
we are actually having these reactions
then I think that that's the next step
we don't want any employee
a uniform that they're not comfortable
with Hector Adler is a senior vice
president with American he says the
airline has offered a number of
alternatives allowing workers to wear
their old uniforms reimbursing them for
purchasing look-alike items providing
uniforms with different materials and
they're in the process of rolling out
new uniforms from a different
manufacturer why not recall the universe
why not just start over with that new
option let me say that right now we are
focused on getting this right and
working with individuals on a
case-by-case basis to address their
concerns but they're not addressing all
of Joshua's car Posey's concerns I'm
still next to people who are wearing the
uniform when I sit on my jump seat I try
to give a couple inches of space between
me and the other person because my first
trip back after my ER visit I got a rash
just from sitting next to someone
wearing it is it worth staying where
you're working if it's risking your
health I believe in American and I
believe that they're gonna do what's
right for their employees and for the
business I'm willing to stick around a
wait and see just how they address this
issue the same manufacturer has faced
criticism before in fact Alaska Airlines
flight attendants unsuccessfully sued
the company over the uniforms a few
years ago now in a statement to CBS News
Twin Hills says it has yet to receive
any medical or scientific evidence
indicating there is anything unsafe
about the uniforms as for what's causing
the problems Nora that remains an open
question
very interesting story Chris thank you
so much